[Musique]
bonjour les grands gourmands bonjour
radio 1 bonjour jacques vous allez bien
mais bien sûr vous et vous je vais bien
merci
et aujourd'hui nous avons proposé une
recette de pâte à vous il ya même des
alors les raviolis alors à l'italienne
peut-être peut-être mais vous dire que
maintenant les revenus ont dépassé bien
les la frontière de l'italie et c'est
devenu très très à la mode des raviolis
dans les bandes signés fin alors on va
commencer par faire la pâte que tu
avoues i nous allons casser les deux os
oui oui je vous fais une très petite
part à faire là disons très peu deux
frères kg alors vous me passez là pour
la fourchette
il commence comme une armure la science
est restée relativement simple voilà
alors un peu de semoule de blé dur de
semoule fine
ah oui et ce n'est pas de la farine ont
alors un peu de farine 2 cuillerées
environ alors seles à l'angle la semoule
de blé dur la seule oui oui si vous
l'aimez et bien sûr j'y ajoute encore un
peu de semoule de façon à faire une pâte
assez homogène et on travaille on a eu
les doigts
voilà alors oui c'est un bijou vous ni
allemande
vous avez les mains surtout bas via ses
origines vous avez vous travaillé à la
main mais là on est obligé
voilà je suis en faire une boule que je
vais laisser reposer pendant une demi
journée
mais au préalable j'en ai fait à huy une
à la rance bien cl de coca reposer comme
64e date en une demi-journée de faire
laissez reposer d'accord bien
alors attention à nous occuper des
champignons il donne nous avons trois
sortes de champignons alors des
pleurotes frêche
oui oui des champignons de paris
les champions de paris à l'arrêt puis
long et puis des bolets j'ai des volets
d'accord à peu marbre alors de choisir
d'autres sortes de champignons
maintenait bien sûr suivant la saison
des blancs des petits rouge des près vie
trompettes de la mort moulin vous là bon
il faut quand même prendre des
champignons bien faire fumer
oui oui est différente et vous fait ça
avec le hachoir traditionnel riz alors
ce qui est important c'est de ne pas les
acheter trop faim avec au menu bien vous
regardez folie voilà je pense que c'est
bon j'espère que c'est bon mais oui donc
ce sera bon baden que ça mais en fait ça
qui nous allons vous faire suer pendant
15 minutes ces champignons d'accord
alors dans une poêle nous avons fait
fondre un peu de beurre oui on a tous
âges y ajouter les champignons
d'accord tout ouïe dangereux qu'il ya
des noix aussi alors faut pas les
oublier les noises c'est ce qui renforce
le goût c'est très bon d'accord alors on
la savait qu'il en allait aussi d'accord
également adjugé richy alors lâché
grossièrement les noix ou alors de
l'échalote et du persil d'accord voilà
et ont été différées persie est une
échalote nous allons laisser suer à
découvert pendant quelques minutes on
ajoute du seul un peu de sel un peu de
poids il faut bien ça les connaît bien
ce soit
est relevé alors on laisse reproduire
pendant quelques minutes
oui pendant ce temps je vais vous
découpez les les raviolis alors j'ai
étendu la pâte très très minces et pro
japon alors on le remarque pas ce qu'on
veut les dessins du fonds
j'espère que vous allez pouvoir
concourir à un championnat de culture s
voilà je découpe les fonds de raviolis
ou et voilà c'est là peut être on
aimerait bien reposé alors ça c'est avec
à 20h40 sont deux couvercles voile avec
l'emporte-pièce rond si on n'a pas ça on
peut le faire qu un verre vous voyez
n'est bien sûr de le faire dans le
garage vous trouverez sans doute quelque
chose bien sûr vous est d'environ 7
centimètres de mettre d'accord alors là
j'y ajoute la farce
il en faut très peu on l'a dit est pas
vraiment chaude donc beaucoup de
produits chinois voilà
we love le 2ème radio lycienne jeu
badigeonne à l'oeuf battu c'est moi qui
l'ait battu voilà bien battu et demie 1
et laisse à ses poulains pour con alors
pour bien coller les bords du couvercle
et dites moi c'est un sacré travail à
mais bien sûr oui c'est assez long à
faire et la deuxième la deuxième à
baisse on appuyait voilà bon on vous
regarde vers le deuxième a bien précisé
les bonzes sud
c'est vraiment bien bien modèle en fait
on ne la fait bien d'autres on n'a pas
montré la beauté les spectateurs ce
serait trop long je les hits légèrement
ah oui c'était pas pour faire le retour
des engrais pour évaluer laird qui fait
chauffer de l'eau pour les cuirs et nous
nous occupons de la sauce de la petite
sauce nous allons diluée une tranche de
foie gras dans une casserole
oui oui nous allons la faire fondre oui
j'y ajoute un bouillon de volaille et un
peu de truffes
y attachez vous dit se refusant à l'envi
c'est versailles à loches de l'eau un
peu d'eau très peu comme ça donc au
mieux et on va laisser barça où il à
petit feu bon je regarde où l'on savait
c'est bon on va pouvoir faire cuire la
loire les raviolis bien alors je voulais
apporter on a encore le plus simple nous
avons sans les loups oui bien sûr l'eau
bien se doit la wii car la pâte n'est
pas salé oui oui faut en tenir compte et
nous allons laisser cuire combien de
temps modèle deux minutes 2 minutes 10
ans recoins très longtemps alors votre
petite sauce madeleine nous avons diluer
le bouillon de volaille dans très peu
d'eau ensuite nous en avons ajouté à peu
près un demi litre oui et c'est une
sorte de buyo oui avec un peu de beurre
pour vyas diluez la force vient alors
oui on la verse dans les assiettes qu'on
a préparé des affreux the wheel et bien
sûr oui d'enfants des assiettes c'est un
bouillon magnifique elle crée petit jeu
qu'on peut maintenant qu'un peu alors
les raviolis les raviolis sont cuits vie
nous les avons bien laisser quatre
minutes
oui oui en fait nous avons dit dans ces
deux c'est vraiment la paix alors quatre
minutes à partir de l'ébullition et le
troisième raviolis bien madeleine la
morale de cette histoire c'est que les
raviolis c'est bien plus simple de les
acheter en bois et oui mais c'est bien
moins bon c'est certainement moins bon
je vous dirai ça après les avoir goûtés
merci beaucoup me donne encore une fois
on vous retrouve alors jeudi prochain
dans le 12 13
à très bientôt bonnassies dit au revoir
au revoir
[Musique]